[Music]
if you're working with large amounts of
data being able to analyze share and
visualize that data can be a key part of
how your business makes decisions
whether you're building operational
dashboards to improve corporate
performance building Financial reports
and analyzes or building operational
dashboards to improve corporate
performance building a data warehouse
and visualizing that data is essential
knowing what tools to use and how to
combine them to create the
visualizations you need may feel like an
overwhelming task that's why we created
a jumpstart solution that demonstrates
how you can build a data warehouse in
Google Cloud using bigquery as your data
warehouse with looker Studio as a
dashboard and visualization tool
when Building Solutions using a data
warehouse developers will need to
consider several things when populating
and transforming your data for a data
warehouse
how and where the data is sent from your
data sources
what orchestrates the data movement
how the data is transformed and stored
how the data is used for analysis
and how dashboards are created from the
data to perform more analytics
additionally you'll need to spend time
determining what tools and products are
best suited to accomplish these steps
instead of building your own solution
from scratch our jumpstart solution
allows you to quickly and easily deploy
a working solution to exploring your own
and help you determine what tools and
solution flow work best for your needs
allowing you to focus on analysis and
not the underlying infrastructure if
you'd like to make your own changes and
customize it further we've also built
the foundation of the solutions in
terraform which you can pull locally and
modify as much as you'd like and while
these Solutions aren't built to be
production ready they do include
examples patterns and the Google Cloud
tools we recommend you consider when
building your own Warehouse Solutions
our solution deploys and analyzes New
York City Taxi data to understand taxi
company performance over time let's
quickly review the architecture of the
Google Cloud resources that the solution
deploys
the architecture used represents a
common data flow to populate and
transform data for a data warehouse
First Data is sent to a cloud storage
bucket next Cloud workflows facilitates
the data movement data is then loaded
into bigquery from an external table and
then transformed in bigquery using
Google standard SQL and lastly
dashboards are created from the data to
perform more analytics by using looker
Studio
to try out this jumpstart solution
yourself simply click deploy and our
solution will guide you through these
steps and automatically create and
configure all the resources needed to
run this solution this solution can be
deployed from the console or by using
terraform once deployed you're free to
explore how the solution is built and
determine what tools and architecture
from this jumpstart solution can be used
for your own data warehouse needs
want more information resources and
troubleshooting tips check out the
solution guide this is this is your best
resource for any questions you have on
this jumpstart solution
remember this solution is for
demonstration purposes only and is not
intended to be used in a production
environment however feel free to play
around and customize it before creating
your own architectures based on the
framework provided in this jumpstart
tutorial ready to try it out for
yourself check out the links in our
description to deploy this jumpstart
solution and see additional learning
resources to dive deeper on this topic
we'll see you in the cloud
[Music]